let's think about the units typically
used in the metric system to measure and
objects to measure an object's weight
and I'm putting the weight in quotation
marks right over here because the units
I'm going to talk about are actually if
we wanted to be technical their units of
mass and as we'll see later on in our
scientific in our in our scientific
careers that weight and mass are not the
same thing they are related mass you
could view is how much stuff there is
what's the how much substance does an
object have how hard is it to change the
the velocity of an object while weight
is what's the force that gravity is
pulling down on that object now in
everyday life on if we're just on the
same planet or the same part of the
planet if something has more mass it's
going to have more weight and it's
something has more weight it's going to
have more mass and that's why in
everyday language these words are often
interchange later on we'll see that
these mean different things for the sake
of this video because we're really just
getting ourselves warmed up with some of
these units I will use these
interchangeably I'll use them in kind of
the everyday language sense not in the
technical physics sense of the word so
in the metric system when people talk
about measuring relatively light things
they will often use the gram and to get
a sense of things that weigh a gram one
example is a paperclip your average
sized paperclip would weigh about a gram
a stick of chewing-gum not even the
whole pack of chewing gum just a stick
of chewing gum would weigh would weigh
about would weigh about a gram a dollar
bill would weigh about would weigh about
a gram so this really isn't this really
isn't a lot of weight now if you wanted
to measure things more on I would say a
human scale you could then increase by a
factor of thousand and go to the
kilogram kilogram and as the unit
implies as the prefix implies I should
say kilo a thousand this means 1,000
grams and if you want to think about how
much that represents well many people
will measure their weight in terms of
kilograms so I for example weigh weigh
about about 70
70 kilograms and I'm five nine and I'm
about average average build and I weigh
about 70 kilograms if you want to
imagine what a kilogram is like imagine
taking a liter of fluid so if you are a
liter of water so if you took a liter of
water so and a liter
you can imagine as a ten centimeter deep
cube ten centimeters wide and ten
centimeters high if you fill this up
with water the weight of that thing is
going to be one kilogram and things I
know you're not used to walking around
with with with one liter cubes of water
another way of thinking about it if you
go to the supermarket and you were to
buy a two liter of soda you were to buy
a two liter of soda and sometimes you
can buy two liters of other things as
well water or whatever if you buy a two
liter two liter of soda is going to
weigh is going away well actually two
liters of water in particular is going
to weigh soda has other things in it so
you can't you can't be as precise with
the weight but two liters of sort of
water I should say are going away are
going away exactly two kilograms if we
don't want to run it we're just taught
talking about the water itself we're not
talking about the container but if you
want to get a rough sense for how much
weight that is that's going to be two
kilograms so if you're measuring you
know human scale size things a
reasonable size quantities of fluid
objects around this scale kilogram makes
a lot more sense if you measure these
very light things you're talking about
you're talking about a gram if you want
to get really precise so this might be
more in things if you're doing you know
a drug dosage and you will need to be
very very very precise then you will
sometimes see people go to the milligram
the milligram but you could imagine a
milligram is one thousandth one
thousandth of a gram and so one
thousandth the weight of a dollar bill
or one thousand the weight of a
paperclip this is very very very very
small so this usually doesn't come into
play in our in our everyday in our
everyday life